James two new Queens are revving up the
RuPaul's Drag Race live at the Flamingo
and they are here to give us a head
start I should say welcome ladies thanks
for having us we have Aquaria hello
and then fresh out of season 14. Georgia
hello good morning good morning as
always
always morning in Georgia's world
now let's take it back a moment all
right let's let's go back where was that
moment in your lives where you realize
this was your fabulous Destiny I don't
know what it was like honestly seeing my
face on the Las Vegas Strip that was
that was kind of a moment
um and yeah I feel like the both of us
started our drag Journey so young and
got some really heavy affirmation uh
from it very early in our careers too so
I feel like they set us up really good
to just go to the Moon yeah I love it I
love it what about you judges honestly
when RuPaul said that I was born to do
drag I was like okay
you know what I mean and girl look at me
and aquarium we're out here doing it in
Vegas y'all now look at y'all now so
talk about your experience that you are
just fresh off of season 14. talk about
the experience on the show and and just
how it was for you oh my god what'd you
learn about yourself oh my God honestly
watching the show you learn so much
about yourself watching yourself on TV
and all this stuff but I remember when I
was doing the show I was always so quiet
and always so shy but like and now
watching myself
okay a tour in the world you like really
like learn so much about yourself and
like meeting all the fans and performing
at all these different places it's like
a dream come true it really is and I was
I was looking I was stalking grams and
and let's talk style because that's a
huge part of RuPaul's Drag Race of just
drag life in general you're giving like
high fashion edgy rock star what's your
inspiration I mean for me I guess as
easy to say um like Lady Gaga she's like
we love that I love it because I just
love switching up the looks
um you know playing with gender playing
with shapes and style and color and
stuff and and for me every day that I
get into drag is a new day to become a
different version of aquarius so uh I
just love having a little bit of variety
with my style I love it and George's
from from season 14 to now the strip
what can we expect from you guys what
new energy are you bringing to the show
oh my God the new looks are everything
let me just say the looks are sickening
and the choreography and the show oh my
God so much dancing we are up in the air
flying in the air like there's so much
flying in the air strings are attached
of course
of course now what about you they're
specific big performance that we should
definitely make sure we catch I'm from
Aquaria it's a 90-minute show so you've
got to be planted for the whole 90
minutes although you will want to be up
and clapping as well I love my solo
number it's all fashiony and very camp
and very stylized and dramatic and I too
am flying up in the air so I don't know
where we got these superpowers from but
it's something about being a queen it's
something about it right it's just
something about it well speaking of
something about being a queen is there
just a move that somebody out there
really wants to get into their drag
queen bag finally let free I have no
idea what do they need to know how to do
for me well I don't know if everyone can
do the splits and the dips but I feel
like just like no I have a toast
I love that and how can people get
tickets you can get your tickets right
now through the end of 2023 at RuPaul's
Drag racelive.com that was beautiful
thank you or Ticketmaster as well oh
thank you and you know all the details
hello
again performs through Monday or
Thursday through Monday at 9 30 p.m
again take it for performances for the
end of 2023 are on sale now at
ticketmaster.com drag race Vegas or
RuPaul's Drag Race live.com ladies thank
you so much thank you